Okay. Now let's start working on some real code here.
We're going to do an extended example.
This is going to reflect what you'll be doing in your homework
for this Unit quite closely.
We're going to be using the Google App Engine Datastore
and this is the database provided by App Engine
that is actually pretty cool to use.
A couple things that are worth pointing out:
What we've been referring to as tables
are known as entities,
in the Google App Engine Datastore.
They serve, basically, the same purpose,
which is how you organize things of the same data type together.
Instead of having a table for links, you would have an entity called Link,
and then you would have a bunch of links.
A couple things about entities:
The columns are not fixed.
That is, in a table, you had to have a fixed number of columns
that you define when you define the table
and in the Google App Engine entity
you can have whatever columns you want--
even entities of the same type don't have to have the same columns.
This makes development, actually, a lot easier.
When you're working with tables, often
you build your table and you add a feature,
and then you realize--oh, I needed this column,
and then you have to add that column.
And sometimes adding a column to a database with
millions of rows can be quite troublesome.
In Google, we don't have that problem; you can have whatever columns you want.
You can actually change the columns while you're developing.
It's very handy.
Entities all have an ID,
and this ID can either be assigned automatically by the Datastore,
which is what we'll do in most cases--or you can make up your own ID.
So if you want to use integers or if you want to use
strings--you can use whatever you want, but
every entity has an ID field.
And another important thing that will be a factor, going forward,
is that entities have this notion of parents and ancestors.
And this is a relationship to other entities
that has a couple of very specific use cases.
So--keep going with our link example--
if we had an entity called a Link,
it might have a parent that is Reddit.
Then we can do queries to say get me all of the links
that are a child of Reddit.
And this has some interesting notions
with regard to consistency
in the App Engine database.
So it's not something we need to understand deeply,
and to be honest, I'm just learning how to use the Datastore myself.
So I am, by no means, an expert in how the Datastore works.
But something that's important is that if you give your
entities a parent, you can get around some limitations on consistency,
which is one of the things I'll talk about.